>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
FACING ANOTHER TRAVEL NIGHTMARE.
THIS TIME THE FAA FORCED TO
GROUND ALLUS FLIGHTS FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE 9-11.
IT CAUSED MORE THAN 9,000
DELAYS.
THE PROBLEM WAS AN ISSUE IF THE
SYSTEM THAT ALERTS PILOTS TO
HAZARDS.
JOE BIDEN HIS TEAM IS LOOKING
INTO IT.
>> I JUST SPOKE WITH BUTTIGIEG.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CAUSE
IS.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> THAT BOOSTS MY CONFIDENCE.
DESPITE BOY WONDER PETE
BUTTIGIEG INVESTIGATING THE
ISSUE HE STILL DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS COULD HAVE HAPPENED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
WHAT THE ORIGINAL SOURCE OF THE
ERRORS OR CORRUPTED FILES COULD
HAVE BEEN.
ONE OF THE THINGS I AM ASK FROM
THE FAA IS WHAT IS THE
STATE-OF-THE-ART IN THIS MESSAGE
TRAFFIC?
>> WHEN THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH
A GOVERNMENT SYSTEM, WE WILL
FIND IT AND FIX IT.
MY TOP PRIORITY IS TO UNDERSTAND
THE ROOT CAUSE AND HOW IT LED TO
THIS LEVEL OF DISRUPTION.
>> HE DID TWEET ON THIS.
THAT FOR HIM IS REALLY GOOD.
HE'S ADORABLE WHEN HE TWEETS.
>> I CHECKED AND THE AIRPORT IN
AFGHANISTAN DID NOT HAVE ANY
INTERRUPTIONS AND BEIJING IN
CHINA DIDN'T AND IN NORTH
KOREA'S AIRPORT IS STILL
OPERATING.
THEY HAD NO PROBLEM.
WE DID.
PETE BUTTIGIEG OVERSAW THE
REBRANDING OF THIS FAULTY SYSTEM
TO MAKE IT MORE INCLUSIVE.
THE QUESTION IS:
IT THE FAA GOT $5 BILLION IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, WHY THIS IS
THIS THING NOT REPAIRED?
WHY ARE WE SEEING MORE DELAYS
AND MORE CANCELLATIONS THAN I
CAN REMEMBER?
THE FIRST TIME EVERY PLANE IS
DOWN AND CAN'T MOVE SINCE 9-11,
21 YEARS AGO.
THAT DOESN'T SAY MUCH FOR PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
AT THE END, HE WAS IN CHARGE
WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS.
HE WAS ON PATERNITY LEAVE WHEN
THE SHIPS WERE OFF THE COAST IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND HE WAS ON VACATION IN
PORTUGAL WHEN THEY TRIED TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE RAIL WORKERS
AND GOES BACK AND FORTH TO NEW
YORK CITY AND DOESN'T USE
A SHUTTLE LIKE EVERY ONE OF US.
HE IS AIRING GANT AND DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT HE IS DOING --
ARROGANT AND DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
HE IS DOING.
>> THE JUDGE BRINGS UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY TOOK $1-TRILLION.
WHERE DID IT GO.
TOO EARLY TO CONDEMN THIS?
>> A LITTLE BIT.
>> I DON'T CARE.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE EARLY
ENOUGH.
WORSE THAN WATER GATE AND 9-11
AND JESSE'S SHOW.
>> YOU HAVE ONE CABINET
SECRETARY AND HE IS ALWAYS
LOOKING INTO IT.
THE INCLUSIVE PART IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THEY DID IN DECEMBER OF
2021 THEY CHANGED IT FROM NOTICE
TO AIR MEN TO NOTICE TO AIR
MISSIONS.
>> THANK GOD!
>> AIR MEN IS SO OFFENSIVE.
>> WE SOLVED THAT BIG PROBLEM.
>> THE OTHER REASON THIS NOT
A TERRIBLE THING FOR AMERICANS
TO GO THROUGH RIGHT NOW IS TO
ASK OURSELVES A QUESTION:
IF CANADA PRIVATIZED THE AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROL AND IT WORKS
WELL.
IT'S MORE EFFICIENT.
WHY WOULDN'T WE CONSIDER DOING
THE SAME THING HERE?
WHY SHOULD THE GOVERNMENT BE IN
CHARGE?
>> EXCELLENT QUESTION.
IF WE IMPEACHED MAYOR PETE WOULD
ANYBODY NOTICE.
MAYBE IT'S NOT HIS FAULT.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO.
THAT CAN BE AN ISSUE IN
GOVERNMENT.
>> CHECK THE RATE TOGS SEE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN WITH MAYOR PETE WAS
IMPEACHED.
COMING OFF A TERRIBLE HOLIDAY
SEASON FOR TRAVEL, NOT GREAT FOR
THIS TO HAPPEN.
U.S. AIR SPACE CLOSED.
WE HEAR IT'S NOT A CYBER ATTACK.
DOESN'T THIS MAKE US A TARGET
FOR A CYBER ATTACK.
IF IT CAN FAIL ON ITS OWN
SHOULDN'T RUSSIA SAY THIS IS
WHAT WE SHOULD GO AFTER?
A LOT OF PILOTS WERE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND DOING TV ADS AND KNEW
ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY.
WHY DIDN'T WE KNOW ABOUT IT
YESTERDAYO PEOPLE DIDN'T GO TO
THE AIRPORT?
YOU DON'T HAVE AS MANY PROBLEMS?
>> MAYOR PETE HID IT FROM US.
I AM GLAD YOU SAID THAT.
JESSICA, FINALLY I AGREE WITH
YOU.
MAYOR PETE IS HIDING DANGEROUS
SECRETS FROM AMERICA.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
JUST PAINTING A PICTURE OF WHAT
WAS GOING THROUGH MY LITTLE
LIBERAL MIND THIS MORNING ABOUT
IT.
SOME OF THE MONEY HAS TO GO TO
FIXING THE SYSTEM THAT SEEMS
OUTDATED.
WHEN HE WAS ON PATERNITY LEAVE
HE HAD A CHILD ON A VENTILATOR
SO YOU SHOULD BE WITH YOUR
CHILD.
>> JESSICA MAKES AN EXCELLENT
POINT.
WHAT WAS MAYOR PETE DOING
YESTERDAY?
HE COULD HAVE STOPPED THIS.
WHEN YOUR HEAR THAT FROM
A DEMOCRAT, SAYING THAT, YOU
KNOW THERE IS REAL TROUBLE HERE.
>> I AM JUST PROUD OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
EVERY SINGLE FLIGHT IN THE
COUNTRY WAS CANCELLED AND NOT
A SINGLE HOMICIDE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> I EXPECTED A MASS CASUALTY
EVENT.
GOOD FOR YOU GUYS.
NO BLUNT TRAUMA.
>> WHAT DO YOU DO ON LAYOVERS?
>> YOU DRINK.
>> THE FACT THAT PEOPLE DRANK
AND DIDN'T ASSAULT EVERYBODY, WE
HAVE COME A LONG WAY.
I AM NOT SAYING MAYOR PETE --
LIN, HERE'S WHAT I WANT.
IF THIS HAPPENS I WANT TO SEE
FEROCITY.
I WANT TO SEE SOMEONE LIKE THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE!
THIS IS NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN
AGAIN.
THIS CAN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
I WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS
AND I WILL STAY HERE AND TAKE
EVERY QUESTION.
PETE LOOKS LIKE HE IS 12 BECAUSE
HE IS NEVER STRESSED.
WE WILL FIX IT.
WE GOT THIS.
NO, I DON'T WANT THAT.
I AM NOT SAYING IT'S HIS FAULT,
NOT SAYING HE DOWNLOADED
A VIRUS.
BUT HE SETS THE TONE FOR THE
FAA.
THE TONE IS WOKE.
THEY ARE NOT SPENDING MONEY ON
COMPUTERS WHICH ARE 40 YEARS ON.
THEY ARE CHANGING THE WORD AIR
MEN BECAUSE A TRANSVESTITE PILOT
MIGHT BE OFFENDED.
>> IT'S THEY.
HE SAID TRANSVESTITE.
>> IT'S ALL RIGHT.
>> WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT DURING
THE COMMERCIAL BREAK.
>> IT'S 2023.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
LET'S GET INTO THIS THING.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
>> DON'T DO IT.
>> IT'S IF MY EAR.
DON'T DO IT.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT I